on this remote hilltop base more than a
hundred and eighty recruits complete
basic training with the free Burma
Rangers or FBR they say they're a
humanitarian movement working to help
free the oppressed in Myanmar Jam Wan is
from the northern Shan State where he
says ethnic groups are suffering at the
hands of the country's military there
are many human rights abuses our people
got raped and tortured it's happening to
us and many ethnic groups in Myanmar men
and women take part in fitness drills
and training scenarios to deliver aid
and treat civilians wounded in areas of
conflict these people come from states
of catch in Shan cayenne and rakion
where there are fragile ceasefires and
sporadic fighting the FBR is privately
funded and was founded 25 years ago by
former US Special Forces member and
Pastor David Eubanks and he wants me
Emma's government to be held to account
shelling and displacing villagers that's
attempted murder and in some cases
murder and burning their their homes so
that's another war crime many here are
members of ethnic armed groups who say
they're helping to protect ethnic groups
from the country's army but according to
local media
Myanmar's army brigade general Zhao
Minturn says the group is not to be
trusted and could be escalating the
conflict he says they're militants and
according to information he received
they're asked to attack outposts as a
way of testing their training and from
the United States Republican congressman
Ralph Abraham is visiting the group as
part of a fact-finding trip Emil Muzz
ethnic regions we in America hopefully
have the max of the people here that
won't democracy they want their freedom
they want their independence and my job
is to carry that message back to the
States the UN General Assembly has
condemned human rights abuses against a
Hindu Muslims and other minorities in
Myanmar the country's also
a charge of genocide at the
International Court of Justice the
militant Myanmar is determined to create
a proper British nationalist state the
two divisions are deployed against Roja
and they have been responsible for most
of the war claims against the region
minorities those same divisions have now
been deployed against many of these
other ethnic minorities away from the
accusations between the FBI and
Myanmar's military these people say this
training camp is their first chance to
unite minorities who say they're being
persecuted nor about a manly al Jazeera